Speaker 1: All right.
Let's look at a couple of other things from
the Trump rally over the weekend.
There were a number of esteemed dignitaries
and very high profile guests at this rally
in Waco, Texas, to kick off the 2024 campaign
for Donald Trump.
One such dignitary was Ted Nugent.
And Ted Nugent kicked off the rally in Waco
by saying that Russian I'm sorry.
Ukrainian President Volodymyr Zelensky is
a, quote, homosexual weirdo, which I have
to admit I have not heard before.
Speaker 2: I want my money back.
I didn't authorize any money to Ukraine, to
some homosexual way weirdo.
Now I want my money back.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Sounding like a whining child.
But in all seriousness, as we've talked about
before, some of the biggest applause lines
among the American right wing over the last
two years are overtly homophobic and transphobic
lines.
And that was indeed the case at the Trump
rally.
Maybe my favorite moment from any recent rally,
including this one, was a guy who got up on
stage and instead of promising to fix the
supply chain, he said he would fix the chain
supply.
Speaker 2: I've got a plan to fix the chain
supply of these people.
Speaker 1: If you if you were aware of the
distinct lack of chains that we have in this
country, this guy is going to fix it for you.
Speaker 2: I've got a plan to fix the chains.
It's called Reelect Donald Trump.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: So anyway, very soon chains will
be back in the United States.
Here's another really interesting moment.
One of Trump's attorneys who also moonlights
as an anchor for Right Side broadcasting,
Cristina Bobb, she spoke to a guy who brings
up that he served in the Marines and then
she says, oh, what's your M.O.?
WEST Now, that's just a specialty.
It's a it's super general.
It's like, oh, avionics or like intelligence.
It's super just super, super.
General M West is are not classified in any
way or secret or confidential.
And the guy reacts weirdly to the point where
five different current and former Marines
wrote to me and said, David, this guy's lying.
No former Marine would answer this question
in this way.
You tell me what you think.
Is this guy making it up?
Here we go.
Speaker 4: Did you serve?
Speaker 2: I did.
Speaker 4: Where'd you serve.
Speaker 2: Marine?
Speaker 4: What was your.
Speaker 2: I'm aware I was special.
Speaker 4: Oh, I see.
Okay.
Speaker 2: Oh, I flew into places.
Speaker 4: Okay.
Where are you?
Speaker 2: Places.
Speaker 4: Where are you staying?
Speaker 2: I can't go into detail.
Okay, but.
Speaker 4: This interview's over.
Speaker 1: It's all super, super secret.
Now, again, M0 West just means military, occupational
specialty.
It's just a super general rule.
Were you in personnel and administration?
Were you in logistics?
The guy could have just said I was in intelligence,
I was in avionics, I was whatever.
It's really tough to tell whether it's completely
made up.
But again, current Marines wrote to me and
said, David, this stuff stinks to high heaven.
This guy is just straight up making it up.
If he did serve and he's just wacky right
now because he's, you know, infected with
the Trump virus, fine.
But many members of the military in our audience
extraordinarily skeptical about this guy's
story.
Then a January 6th, indeed, as I understand
it, named Mickey was there and gave a very
strange interview, is the only way I can describe
it in isolation.
Speaker 4: 51 of those days read nothing but
the repo man goes on the back foot in my mouth.
My Lord Jesus, my God Almighty, and the support
of a nation.
And I knew that in my heart.
I knew that my -48 family, you know, my friends
maybe, and family, the whole world can cause
crazy.
We don't care.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 4: Oh, I could not have done it without
my friends and family to my trip.
You don't know what your mantra is one year
to year three.
Speaker 1: Anyway, I'm not going to continue
with this.
It goes on for a long time, but it just to
the untrained eye, it seems like very, very
significant mental illness.
Here's another guy who wants to do a citizen's
arrest of Alvin Bragg.
There is an idea Alvin Bragg, of course, the
Manhattan district attorney, who might might,
might indict Donald Trump.
Speaker 3: For itself, arrest Alvin Bragg.
Alvin Bragg is overstepping his boundaries.
We the people are calling for the arrest of
Alvin Bragg for crimes of treason, election
interference.
I don't even know if that's a crime, but election
Speaker 1: Obstruction, that's the critical
moment from the interview.
He's furious and he's confident that Alvin
Bragg should be arrested, but he's not actually
sure whether the things he's mentioning to
justify Alvin Bragg's arrest are crimes beautifully
emblematic of.
This entire thing just.
Speaker 3: As even lying to a grand jury.
Trump done nothing wrong.
We're here to show support for the greatest
president ever.
Donald Trump.
Arrest Alvin Bragg.
You know, in South Carolina, you could do
citizen's arrest.
Yeah.
So if Alvin Bragg ever comes to South Carolina,
arrest him.
Speaker 1: There you go.
So a very, very patriotic idea there.
And then what else do I have here?
Lastly, here is a woman who says she's a South
African MAGA preacher who had God come to
her in a dream and told her to move to the
United States and try to support Donald Trump,
which again, this would likely be medicated
in most psychiatric situations.
Speaker 4: Amazing.
What's your name and where are you from?
My name is Lindy and Hopley and I am a South
African MAGA preacher.
No.
Do you live in South Africa?
No, I'm living in America because God actually
told me that there's a revival coming to America.
And in the dream that I had, President Trump
was in it.
Speaker 1: So this is totally normal.
Speaker 4: I'm all about just praying for
this country and seeing God get his full reward.
That's amazing.
Where do you live?
Here in the United States?
I'm in DFW, so we came down with the Trump
train, with all the Texans, you know, going
crazy.
All the truck.
Speaker 1: Going crazy is about right.
Speaker 4: It's just honking and going wild.
It's so great to see how many patriots there
are and so many supporters of just this great
movement.
Fantastic.
What is it about President Trump that you
love so much?
Well, to be honest, I just started dreaming
about him.
I am you know, I have a prophetic gift.
And the Lord started speaking to me about
him.
Speaker 1: Totally, not just conversations
with the Lord.
She's a prophet.
Speaker 4: And in my one dream, I actually
feel because I'm totally not political, I'm
a minister, I travel around the world.
You had me for one.
He said, Shine your light and don't hide it
underneath the basket.
So I was a wild party girl and had an encounter
with No, you were.
I don't see it.
But what I loved about this is that I actually,
in one of my dreams, I sat in front of President
Trump and I knew he was giving me some type
of job, you know, kind of like.
And I said to, I'm the Lord in my dream.
I said, I don't want to lose my ministry for
this.
Speaker 1: All right.
So anyway, as we've talked about before, mental
illness, not a joke.
Very sad.
Need to increase access to mental health treatment
in the United States.
Let's leave it there with the South African
MAGA preacher.
But that is what this is where we are right
now as far as the Trump movement.
And it is a really scary and sad thing.